let's get that post up ASAP bird I'm
gonna start doing that I think I think I
just invented something vlog just every
time I say ASAP and just grap for a
little bit paused after because that's
my man show some sort of highlight there
if I could rap I'd be [ __ ] rapping I
would have wrapped it all up by now I
would have sold all my businesses I
would be on my way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you made it
you figured it out tell me the whole
story
stop watching lost so like I seen you on
there and was taking oh you're saying
and over like the past I don't know like
seven months since I discovered you like
I feel like sometimes you're like
tugging at me like well I'm going to
work listening to you like because like
a voice I know you like rap music pick a
hair me like spit like I'm not like
internship on internship it's on my
resume in their visual well
communications i got bf8 yeah man
i think we should do it i think it's a
funny story for everybody on the
internet I think I think I think he's
clearly got the skills to be able to do
it and more importantly I think we can
motivate millions of people to go and
get theirs too I think I think we owe it
to him and I think you attack them to
make this higher I think it'll make the
full circle feel real good Grethe good
you guys go jam
headed to wine library now to some
meetings there with my my own internal
media team and then head to the super
tasting which is a super exciting
charity event at Wine Library so should
be a pretty rad bed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I want to activate every part of
definitely as you can imagine
definitely this right whole area people
like there's a lot that can be done yeah
we have unlimited fire powers our you
know it can't be a bad decision for you
guys to jam with me but now it's about
figuring it out right right yeah I mean
how the [ __ ] in that's not work right
let me tell you the story of this event
in 2001 I've been kind of operating and
been in the game now in the business for
about three full years and there was a
couple of wine tastings going on in the
state the laws have changed and allowed
us to do these kind of events without
charity liquor laws are very difficult
so many laws can't do a lot of things
and I thought it was our time to jump
into the Perret of this and so I started
kind of like strategizing it in the
summer of in this late spring summer of
2001
Brandon Warneke who some of you know and
Bobbie Shiffrin my cousin also both who
I was just both talking to outside who
are the main cogs in this business
besides me and my dad I decided to send
them on a trip to Spain to taste wine
much to the chagrin of my dad who said
you can't send the two most important
people on a trip together and I said to
my dad you know it's fine I've got this
for a week let them enjoy before the big
tasting you know as some of you know
I've got high energy so not only did I
decide to do our first ever tasting this
event and then but I also decided to
launch our first catalog even though we
were doing the econ thing I was doing
our first catalog so it's a very very
very busy summer and spring that year
thank you
thank you so much I'm really glad you're
here yeah what take a photo awesome it's
a real pleasure I just want to say thank
you so much for all the stuff that you
do glad yes hey and I'll never forget
like it was actually pretty tough even
though I was the business was growing so
quickly that you know everybody came
back from the summer that ball was super
busy plus the catalog plus this tasting
so like even for me you can like go 24
hours a day and do everything I was like
[ __ ] I can't wait till they get back
right so I'll never forget it it was a
the Jets first game of the season Sunday
morning it was Herman Edwards as his
first game as the coach and and we uh I
was getting ready to leave the house
this is back when you still had a home
phone and the phone rings just I mean
literally I had in my hand a knob I'm
leaving the phone rings nobody really
calls me at my house so I decided to
pick it up and it's Brandon telling me
that they missed their flight that they
won't be home because Bobby got kidney
stones and he's in the hospital
in Paris can you do something with
yourself a Bandhan use your skills take
it to five yeah yeah thanks so much
thank you I just started a blog like I
started and we finally found him it's
wrecking Gary love this man next day was
9/11 and I get a crazy call I get a call
from Brandon for some of the old-timers
in this room
remember when nervous phones in the
planes and so he called from the air
Brandon at 9:09 in the morning and said
great news were coming home and I said
to him I'm not sure there's something
weird going on
none of the towers had fallen yet but I
knew the second plane had hit and so was
weird anyway long story short they
landed in Canada they were there for
another four days they didn't get back
into like September 17
this tasting was on this day in 911 so I
guess five weeks after right around the
time where there was even some level of
conversation of maybe debating get back
to normalcy I know a lot of you travel
to be here but for this area it was
hardcore and I'm just super interesting
because I remember my debt it was a very
special night because it helped a lot of
people as one little tiny piece of
getting back to like a fun night and
almost say and so this place this place
this building this event holds a very
near and dear place in my heart but what
I remember more than anything was my dad
pulling up at this point I was really
operating dinner you know and he pulled
up and it was so packed here and there
was so much going on and I remember he
looked at me and he goes what other
event is going on here and I said to
Minnis is our entire event
he was so pumped so proud and it's just
to feel like I've never forgot your dad
yeah of course let me take it
but I got
it's a rare photo flat such a smiley
smile nothing matters to me more than my
family and it's been a lot of fun kind
of like getting involved with Wine
Library a little bit mom you're the most
famous person that's never been on the
show give them some good parenting and
buy something give them something you've
been on the show show guys there you go
got it feeling good there enough mom
give one piece of advice I don't know
something just love him the way I love
him is in my sunshine and you know
starting the wine club which how many
people buy show hands in the wine club
how many not mm-hmm it [ __ ] hurt but
it's amazing somebody very interesting
follow me come here Eric Eric
going on blog this is very important oh
my god this is Eric Godfrey god this is
the man who made me a New York Jets fan
this is not a joke
this man this man in my neighborhood
in the fall of 1982 made me a Jets fan
drew took me to my first Jets game with
his dad like Eric Godfrey this was my
dad's come tonight this is literally my
area I'm your Erica free this is Erica
this is literally the man responsible
for the entire thing when you all how do
you feel about that fantastic
I'm glad to be here I am pretty yeah
it's pretty rad it's pretty rad this man
I haven't seen dad I feel like tonight
this and hopefully it'll be cool for you
guys to say it one day if it continues
to evolve I'm excited to kind of almost
start the next chapter of this event too
you know and uh and I really would like
to do this specific event going forward
no you know I think a lot of you flatter
me with your comments and thoughts but
nobody dreams bigger for them you know
as much as you dream of me accomplishing
my things I dream even greater and so
even when I sit in this room in 27 years
is the owner of the New York Jets I plan
on doing this little event and so I'm
really really thankful for you guys to
be at the first one of this and I
appreciate you guys being here so thank
you
I'll sit down with you for an hour
and we'll do a working session and I'm
thrilled to give you unbelievable
amounts of feedback on the mainly
because I think I'm really in a position
to give you great feedback because this
is because I've been thinking about it
for three years I've been producing
content every day filming everything
with 100% this in mind when when they
asked who came out I have my assistant
she bought a thousand [ __ ] coffee and
I was throwing the [ __ ] petrol in the
[ __ ] booth told my ribbon read the
[ __ ] so on cause that so listen I
get it more than you know I've been
literally building in library of not
only my 2,000 answers every [ __ ] word
out of my mouth yeah I believe in it
more than anybody I think that my legacy
and my brand sits at the top because I'm
Watson
we both got better-looking as we got
older which is very rare
big night
just a group of a perfect night right it
was an event that was a huge thank you
for meaningful charities it was a huge
night for me to give back to my dad and
to my community and to the wine library
customer community and staff and
a good night
I don't think we got it we got it we
didn't get it we got it we got it